welcome to this video playing news ro
this Cesaro do you pronounce it like
that I don't know who is the sky so no
name in them mmm yeah the cattle oh yeah
that's that's very a bit here with the
kettle on hmm run knowledge of those
lines is really a non-existent asics go
I really don't know how the serve okay
now we can go into this line I think
there is something like this and it's
probably and now be 3m some some lines
like that I think there's something like
that now trying to use the center enter
the open lines a line and seen I'll just
be five movies not exactly i'm great in
this structure but it's a pawn i'm not
sure if this exactly as a line a book
line but there's something similar in
know at least similar maybe this is the
positioning in a ver up some Boris a
Brooks book on the catalog or let's say
on one D for the main the main meat of
this book is the Catalan 56 makes a
somewhat weird impression on me but I
know looks like it just runs into a 45
but maybe me4 s not an issue and he more
thinking along lines that II for
the mocks the diagonal I can also play
95 at that look sir looks rather good
even yeah why not oh ok
how to how to improve this possession k
du Luc c1 trying to provoke the capture
not sure if I should do that even I can
also take c6 paratus taking c6 cannot
really help what about this evening is
keep some pieces on the board yeah maybe
complicated um yeah yeah come on and I
want to prevent d 5 maybe it's not such
a big threat but didn't want to deal
with it night c5 now or is this too
shaky
why look do you want either I can I can
go here you intending 95 yeah well this
is not not too bad I mean this is
certainly compensation of some sort not
sure if it is entirely sufficient but
there is some compensation c5 he is
trying to play c5 of course now it's
very delicate than this positions you
can
even if you have compensation some it
can easily am easily deteriorate rather
quickly here protecting okay try to
control C 5 that's not the most that
looks like to grade
can I take the night in some way it
doesn't have a retreat square
I didn't see that my Ruca saying on d3
ah yeah probably Adam it was a bit fishy
anyway I don't know mm-hmm I didn't see
that this is awful yeah probably this
were were too many games in the session
need a break of course you can always
loose against a strong GM but I
overlooked so many moves some it's a bit
much let's let's resize this no no use
you just pull pushing all those pawns
yeah this be scared of positions are
really difficult I think it done but so
it's I think it's pretty clear that
white has some compensation if it's
enough how does how to tell but it's
it's something it's it's not a
compensation which too much with too
much on forward let's say forward
potential it's not just the conversation
that keeps on blacks position at bay but
then maybe this is just temporary he can
play f 62 to kick the night back and
then it's not so clear what it is doing
on a 3 maybe I love John maybe I'm I had
some some better chances before but this
I mean head that it must be kidding
enough for porn really with all those
some strange pieces yeah maybe the fbook
this is maybe half hard to tell them how
you can these kind of positions are very
difficult to analyze because they are
not so so straightforward and concrete
maybe it's not enough I don't know it
looked pretty pretty convincing how he
played this alright thanks for watching